I get always ask this question you know
you were a spy in subtle card in the
months and the years before before 9 11.
how could how could you not have seen it
coming and I would say well we've seen
it coming that something big is going to
happen but the details were so well
guarded because the al-Qaeda was split
into compartments the people who were
trained for that uh in a mission were
trained in a secret camp that was set up
for them and then they themselves in at
least 14 of them 14 out of the 19 did
not know that it was a suicide mission
they thought it was only a hijacking wow
and that's it only five
[Music]
we've met before obviously Eamonn but um
for anyone who's listening or watching
for the first time could you just
introduce yourself tell me who you are
okay well my name is Eamon Dean
um born in Saudi Arabia Bahraini origin
um grew up in Saudi Arabia as a uh a
nerd someone who loves books and you
know reading and I was actually training
to become an Imam I wanted to become an
Imam from a young age
um however life always had you know got
different plans and I ended up you know
joining the Jihad when I was 16 in
Bosnia in 1994.
um after that I never looked back I
ended up going from one place to another
and ended up in the lap of the British
intelligence Services uh four years
later in 1998 after that I worked for
them as a spy for eight years
um up until 2006 after 2006
unfortunately I was outed by a us
journalist and my cover was blown
unfortunately and so I ended up working
in a bank I mean what's amazing there
Raymond is you've given a sort of a very
concise 40 second introduction to
yourself and I feel like you described
about 12 lives three James Bond films so
what we'll do now is we'll get back
all the way to the beginning and we'll
go through that in a little bit more
detail
um thank you for joining us again and
I'm really excited to talk to you about
your life
um so you described growing up as a nerd
in Saudi Arabia what what does that mean
growing up isn't heard in Saudi Arabia
well scientist Society in the 1980s was
a society where young people were more
concerned you know with
either the cars and the new models of
cars or with sports especially football
so I was never interested in in cars or
sports or in football so for me it was
the my past time was reading books
especially on history on geography I'm
someone like who's fascinated by Maps
I'm fascinated by countries their
capitals their populations and you know
you know if you come and asked me at the
age of nine I could recite the capitals
of the world the populations you know
you know and that was hugely odd and I
think in later life
um maybe much later than I thought
realized that maybe that was a form of
autism I don't know but nonetheless when
I was young I was more busy you know
reading than participate painting in
what was the norm what was accepted from
young boys at that time what was
expected I would say
um to kind of take from that that you
were someone that was quite a loner did
you have a big group of friends who are
into similar interests or were you
somebody that kind of stayed away on
their own locked in their room pouring
over Maps
the irony is I wasn't a loner because
the fact that the religious
establishments there in Saudi Arabia
were far more inclusive than what would
one would give them credit for so for
someone like me I would basically end up
joining a an Islamic awareness Circle in
the local mosque that is where I found
my friends I mean in the school I would
have two or three friends who were
closer and have the similar mindset out
of a class of 33 but in the Islamic
awareness Circle where I used to go
almost all the 40 50 people who were
there uh most of them my age or slightly
older were all of them friends
um and I think you know the fact that I
was surrounded by like-minded people was
a blessing and you said a minute ago
that your initial intention had been to
become an Imam so obviously that's a
word that is familiar these days in
popular culture but for anyone who might
not know what it means what isn't Imam
and why did you want to become one well
an Imam is someone who leads the prayers
in the mosque you know he would
sometimes act as a counselor for in the
local people he leads the congregation
and prayers and funerals and someone who
more or less like the local
um you know person for adjudicating
disputes and helping people deal with
their daily uh problems
um I thought this is a noble you know a
profession and I want to really become
one and I made the start by age nine by
age 12 I started to delve deeper into
Islamic theology but the age 12 was far
more important for me on a personal
reason because my mother passed away
when I was 12. you know so that pushed
me further and further towards
understanding theology well that's
quite deep kind of thought processes and
concepts for a 12 year old at this point
are you would you say you were a deeply
religious child or would you say at this
point it was almost more educational and
and cultural was I a religious child or
yes there was no question about it I was
and I was deeply religious I think
because of the fact that uh the fact
that my father passed away at the age of
four and the fact that I was supposed to
be with him in the car
uh uh he died in the car collision and
so
um and if it wasn't for A Shard of glass
that I stepped on in the kitchen before
he was you know supposed to leave the
house and therefore I was supposed to
fix my feet instead of going with him if
I went with him I would have died with
him wow so you know so the question of
Fate was always there because I was
always always asking my mom I would say
you know what is fate and how do we
understand faith and she would say that
Faith sometimes can come in the form of
something minor a minor irritation that
stops you from meeting a unpleasant end
so sometimes what you believe to be a
minor irritation could actually be your
Lifesaver so I've learned from that that
there is a complicated plan in action
and whoever put that complicated plan in
place knows about where my life will end
you know you know whether it is a year
from now or 70 years from now so
therefore I should be on the good side
of whoever put this plan rather than on
the bad side of whoever put that plan
that plan so that is I think you know
why from young age I understood you know
that fate is what control our lives and
therefore I need to understand you know
who put this uh plan together for me and
for everyone else there's quite a lot
there that I'd like to get into a little
bit deeper later on as we go through
your story but I'd like to go back now
to your life as it played out so you're
12 years old uh you're now moving into
Theology of religion how did that end up
becoming somebody who moved into what
would later be described as a terrorist
well
one
of one day and say that I want to become
a terrorist I mean it doesn't happen
like that
you are seduced
process of
um and being lured into it
um and you know
that saying which is you know been said
many times but in my case it's really
true
the road to hell is paved with good
intentions and because I've seen this
not only with me personally but with so
many people around me the road to hell
is paved with good intentions and I've
learned long time ago that good
intentions are not enough
without wisdom
you can this path will lead you to Hell
unfortunately so how it happened I was
born in the Eastern province of Saudi
Arabia and grew up there you know it has
a sectarian divide she hasn't sunnis and
not far away from us in the 1980s you
know the iran-iraq war was raging and it
was actually between a you know Sunni
power Iraq and the Shia power Iran and
in our schools actually there was always
this taunting uh between the two sides
even though we were young but the sunnis
supported Saddam you know the Shia
supported Romania and Iran even though
we were only 11 and 12 year olds and yet
we were taunting each other about you
know who's winning and who's losing as
if it is you know to do with in a
football match rather than like you know
an actual War raging around my mother
come from Lebanon so throughout the 80s
she was worried about her family back
home who were going through
um a vicious Civil War that was ethnic
sectarian and religious
and at the same time when I was uh you
know 11 Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait
and refugees were coming you know from
Kuwait into our town and then uh half a
million foreign troops including you
know many Americans you know came in
order to defend uh Saudi Arabia against
Saddam Hussein and then to expel Saddam
Hussein from Kuwait
I've mentioned to you now you know three
major conflicts happening around me and
I'm experiencing them
it is enough to politicize any child let
alone I mean someone who was already
into geography history and politics so
for me the uh the experience you know I
lived in the 1980s coupled with the fact
that I was deeper into theology uh
prepared me somehow for
um you know accepting the fact that
human conflict is actually an integral
part you know of you know being a human
on this planet that there will always be
a push and pull between People based on
many motives whether they are
territorial religious
um you know economic one way or another
it's our destiny to fight each other am
I right in thinking the the the first
part of your life that saw you fighting
was when you were 16 in Bosnia is that
correct yes could you tell us how you
got there well
when the Bosnian conflict started in
1992 I was watching closely the idea
that there are Muslims who are you know
Europeans and for all intents and
purposes after all that you know they
are Slavic you know people who just
converted to Islam in uh you know in the
16th century and yet they are
slaughtered a mass just because of their
names even though in appearance and even
in DNA they are you know absolute copy
of the subs and yet they were being
killed for their religious identity uh
for me it was shocking and also at the
same time the fact that one of my
teachers in school a math teacher who
come from an affluent family went there
and fought there and died there right so
the fact that the Bosnian conflict even
though it was raging you know 3000 miles
away
it was ever so present in my own
classroom because a teacher you know his
his chair is empty now because he
thought that it didn't matter that he is
from Saudi Arabia uh the solidarity that
religious solidarity with the fellow
Muslims in Bosnia was far more important
and therefore he went there and he died
there for them and for me I thought if
he could do that why couldn't I it's
just the trigger wasn't there
all is needed uh for me to go was a
trigger and a trigger came actually in
uh September of 1994 when a friend of
mine from the same circle from the
Islamic Governor Circle
um who was three years my senior was
about to leave to Bosnia I was going to
his home to say you know goodbye
but in the 10 minutes I was actually
walking to his home I formed my opinion
I formed my mind I finally made my mind
and I said to him I'm gonna going I'm
gonna go with you and I remember he was
saying well look I'm a 19 year old
actually I had a two months training in
Afghanistan in a summer you know uh two
summers ago so
um however why do you think that Jihad
needs you you know you are a nerd you
know and I I can't even you know imagine
you you know carrying an AK-47 I mean so
he said do you really think that Jihad
needs you and I said to him no I need it
and I remember that answer changed his
mind and changed my life I mean he
decided maybe you're right maybe you
know you have the right mindset for it
that you're not going there because you
think it's a picnic all right you know
in an adventure no actually you have the
right mindset to it you said you need it
it means that you know for you you see
the Jihad as a cleansing and a journey
of discovery I see interesting and you
know what stands out to me is that
you were 16 obviously your life has been
exceptionally different to mine in the
you know lead up to being 16 but if I
had made a decision similar to that in
my life even to join the military at 16.
I would have had a group of people
around me who probably would have tried
to talk me out of it until I was a
little bit older or you know classed as
an adult or something like that
the group of people around you at that
point in your life if you said I'm going
to go and join the Jihad would they have
been trying to talk you out of it or was
it something people would be proud of
and saying you know you've made a really
courageous decision like I'm just trying
to get my head around how a 16 year old
makes such an incredible decision and
the people around that person either
allow it or trying to talk you out of it
or what was the process after that well
I mean if I was going to tell everyone
around me you know about my decision to
go to the Jihad in Bosnia I mean in I
would say 95 percent would have tried to
talk me out of it I can tell you that in
fact if I told my five older siblings
that I'm going to the jihadon Bosnia I
mean first of all they will lock me up
in the room first get my passport and
that's it that's the end of it
um so the whole process was secretive
wow wow so you didn't tell your siblings
you didn't tell any extended family no
you made a plan and from the point you
decided to do it to the point that you
were getting on a plane how long was
that well um
I would say about two weeks my God yeah
and you went with your friend absolutely
and two other friends who joined us from
uh Riyadh from the capital of Saudi
Arabia so we were for
um and yeah by October of 1994 we landed
in Bosnia were you scared
no ironically no I was excited and at
that point is that overwriting any
relationships you might have with other
humans so for example you've talked
about your siblings you know
did you feel sadness at the thought you
might never see them again or did you
think when they found out what you'd
done you'd they'd be happy and they'd be
proud of you or what was that kind of
feeling like
when I was at the border that's it like
now I'm 45 minutes you know drive from
the Bosnian border I was in Croatia
um at that time near Dubrovnik and I
um you know decided okay now after five
days disappearance and my family has no
idea where I'd gone so I'm gonna you
know give my uh a home a call and I see
who whoever picks up I will tell them
where I'm going so I uh phoned home and
my older brother picked up and he was
frantic he was saying we were looking
for you everywhere for two days you know
you told us you're going for a a camping
trip in the desert for the weekend then
you will be back and when you were not
back like and we were really worried and
when we called the police the police
said that you've left you left the
country
and you're going to Vienna where are you
going exactly I said well currently I'm
in Croatia so of course they are not
idiots I mean my brothers are all
University graduates and you know
worldly people they traveled so when he
heard Croatia he's you know he heard it
on the news so many times and he said
you know are you going to Bosnia you
know and I said yes and then there was a
moment of silence and then he said are
you going to fight there
so I decided like you know I don't know
what came over my mind like you know I
wanted to just joke with him I said no
I'm going there to harvest onions what
do you expect me to do like and I mean
of course I'm going to fight you idiot
and so you know you know he laughed
nervously but then he said
is there anything I could say or do that
will make you change your mind and come
back
anything just ask for anything
you know all of us like you know
whatever you ask for we will give it to
you just come back
and I would I said to him nothing
seriously I can I'm only 45 minutes from
the border nothing will change my mind
so after I while being silent he just
said to me God be with you and he hung
the phone and that's it
so for anyone watching or listening that
might not understand
um can you explain briefly what the
Bosnian conflict was and who you were
fighting for and who you were fighting
against well as you know and the early
1990s Yugoslavia you know a country that
no longer exists you know
it broke up I mean so it was a union
between six countries you know so you
have Montenegro you have Serbia you have
Croatia Bosnia uh Slovenia and Macedonia
which is now known as North Macedonia so
the these countries were part of a union
but then it started to break up as the
Soviet Union broke up also uh Yugoslavia
broke up and
first it was a war between Croatia and
Serbia and then it turned into then
later a conflict within Bosnia when the
war ended in Bosnia in 14 December of
1995. by that time I was 17 year old
and for me
the sadness I felt is not that we buried
two friends actually so many friends uh
died you know we were the volunteer unit
of the mujah hadim Brigade in Bosnia at
that time used to be about a thousand
and Weber 300 you know uh there in
Bosnia more than that and so I remember
that when I was living it wasn't so so
much the sadness that you know the war
is over the sadness is that I survived
the war wow that is the mindset at that
time and I remember the listener that
was my mindset at that time
um so I felt a sense of failure that the
mission was to die there was that a
well-aimed bullet a well-aimed shell
should find me
but it never found me and for whatever
reason I survived that war While others
won the honor of being masses so
you know so when I was boarding that
plane from uh splitting Croatia to Roman
from there to Istanbul I felt
a sense of failure that you know I
didn't achieve what I wanted to achieve
I would say like my first Jihad
experience ended and I'm still alive so
I have to hop now into the next Jihad
experience so I thought okay where
should I go next and I remember that in
the last days of the Bosnian conflict I
met an Al-Qaeda militant who came to
Bosnia to look for recruits
and when I met him he gave me a phone
number and he said don't go to the
caucuses it's a waste of time go to
Afghanistan the camps are reopening and
there is a new kind of war that you need
to be prepared for go and learn other
military skills useful skills
so that man his name is
who would later become The Mastermind of
9 11. he gave me that phone number and
he said call that phone number
there will be a man called Abu zubaida
now he is a famous inmate in Guantanamo
um that man just tell him I sent you and
he will take care of you he will send
you to the right military camp for you
in Afghanistan so I called him in may of
1996 and I said to him I would love to
come and he said yes no problem at all
you know he fixed a date with me I came
into Peshawar airport
and then I was transported two days
later into Afghanistan
um three months later when after I spent
my time training there Osama Bin Laden
arrived from Sudan running for his life
you know into Afghanistan and started
just the embryonic stages of
establishing Al-Qaeda so in August of
1996 myself and 13 others and who were
mostly from Saudi Arabia and from other
Gulf Arab countries we went to see him
this is Bin Laden yes this is Bin Laden
so and goodness the first time I saw him
I was like is this the famous Bin Laden
because he really looked disheveled he
wasn't well dressed not the same image
that you see always of someone who's
well dress and nice robes and you know
and a turban with no crease in it no no
he was really disheveled and all of the
people around him and that little
compound they looked really as if they
are refugees oh really yeah
um boxes everywhere you know suitcases
everywhere it looked a very disorganized
place
but nonetheless the way he spoke to us
was confident
and he spoke to us about what I call
Islamic eschatology you know he's
talking about the prophecies
and how he believed that his flight from
Sudan to Afghanistan is the beginning of
something big and that there is a
prophecy about it this is the land where
the Muslim armies will rise and will
start their March towards the Middle
East to liberate Arabia to liberate
Jerusalem and to liberate Baghdad and
Damascus
all of these places will be liberated
because of the army we are building here
and you know of course like you know for
me I was looking at him and I was
thinking
an army you're just a bunch of refugees
you just arrived I mean you know how
will you build an army out of this that
is capable of doing all of what you are
trying to achieve and Bin Laden might
have looked disheveled at the time but
actually he gave the impression of being
able to read your mind
it's incredible to sit here with you
it's incredible sit here with you and
think that you're someone who's met
Bin Laden you know who's arguably one of
the most in my lifetime has altered the
course of the world and world history
one of the most iconic figures
and it's also interesting to hear what
you say about meeting him for the first
time and him seeming kind of like a bit
disheveled but he was obviously a very
good speaker because he could change
your mind based on you know your initial
thoughts of him seeming a little bit um
unimpressive was he somebody at that
point in time because obviously
pre-911 I don't think the West would
have ever heard his name but you said
five years before that five years and
one month before that you would you were
aware of him already so was he somebody
that was did he have a big reputation at
that point in that world already
within the jihada circles yes he was a
legend already you know since his
exploits in the Afghan Jihad uh conflict
against the Soviets in 1987 uh what
happened in the in the famous battle of
jaji against a Soviet uh you know
Commandos
um you know 1989 and the withdrawal of
the Soviet forces the 1992 fall of Kabul
and the fall of the communist government
there all of these events you know
always Bin Laden was in the background
and so when he left to Sudan in 1992
people were always you know viewing him
within the jihadist circles as a legend
as a veteran as a hero of that conflict
and what was it what was the what could
he do was it that he was a great leader
was it he was a mastermind was it
stretchy was it Brave you know what was
the thing that people thought about him
he wasn't just an administrator and a
competent one at that he was also a
brave man who would actually go and
fight alongside his subordinates
was it just the first time that you met
him or did you meet him again
subsequently no I met him a few times
after that but most importantly it was
in September of 1997 when I gave him my
oath of Allegiance so that is when I
joined okay the proper and they decided
that well
um you know we are you are not you know
I remember his words to me you don't
look the commando's material you know
you're not going to be enough to end up
in our special he said that here yeah
you know but I know of a better use for
you you know you know and so he sent me
to a specialist Camp which was
developing uh not only uh Cutting Edge
new explosive
um you know uh and bombing materials but
also chemical weapons and biological
weapons and this is where you started to
fulfill your main role in Al Qaeda which
was as a bomb maker well
I was a trainee bomb maker let's put it
this way you know the good thing is that
I never built a device outside of a
training setting so because you see
within 11 months I changed my mind so
luckily and it's because of that
inevitability you see 11 months into my
training you know as a bomb maker and
you know into you know making poisons
and chemical weapons and biological
weapons uh and all of this you know
especially the biological program was
extremely rudimentary but their chemical
weapons was far you know more
sophisticated than I expected but their
explosives uh making was a Cutting Edge
at that time they were pushing the
envelope in when it comes to you know
maximizing you know what they call they
you know the explosive yield you know of
ordinary materials you know that was
brilliant but
at the 11th month in August of 1998
there was an event which basically in a
shook my Consciousness all the way down
to the core I mean I thought that no no
I can't be part of this anymore which
was the East Africa bombings you know in
1998 you know two American embassies Dar
es Salaam in Tanzania and Nairobi and
Kenya the American embassies they were
targeted but in particular what
horrified me was the attack in Nairobi
itself it was a massive bomb
um almost 750 kg of uh High explosives
and it was loaded with shrapnels so many
shrapnos thousands of them and it was
designed to maximize casualties
um
220 people died
12 Americans killed and the rest were
innocent Kenyans somalis ugandans who
were there at the wrong place at the
wrong time
and in addition 5 000 people were
wounded
150 of them were blinded for life God
because of the amount of shrapnels
embedded and I remember prior to the
attacks we tested the 1.3 tons device
there in our camp and so you know I was
aware that they were training us for
massive Mega bombs and I was thinking
you know three four five days after the
attacks and as the information were
still coming and filtering through and
all the
um you know uh you know all the images
were coming through I remember I was
asking myself
one day
they will deploy me you know and I will
be in another Capital another city
another location building a device like
this
now because of the religious education I
had which is by the way much more than
the average alcohol I remember would
have so my exposure to theology is far
greater than
um an average Al-Qaeda or average
hardest you know recruit so that was a
blessing in a sense because I was asking
myself
since I believe in the afterlife because
of all the deaths that was around me
like I mean my father dying my mother
dying you know you know and so for me I
was asking myself one day I will stand
before God and he will
you know ask me the question
all of these people and I will be seeing
their faces in the afterlife
why did you kill them what was the
reason and so so for me I remember I
went to ask the Mufti of al-Qaeda at
that time the dean of the Sharia College
you know yes there in Afghanistan and so
I went to ask him I said to him and he's
Egyptian I said to him you know you know
I'm not doubting anything but just can
you put my heart at peace here how can
we justify killing that huge number of
people
you know you know we're talking about
like you know hundreds of people who had
nothing to do whatsoever you know in the
conflict between us and the Americans uh
not to mention the 5 000 people who are
wounded and so he said that oh we have a
religious justification we have what we
call the tateros fatua what is that he
said the human shield fatwa if the enemy
is hiding behind civilians then we are
allowed you know to do that we have the
permission we have the religious license
and the theological license to do that
so I remember when I uh heard this I
said uh can you tell me where I can find
it and luckily he told me where to find
it it is in the comprehensive works of
eventamia you know a 13th century
Islamic scholar but the problem is it's
37 volumes thank God I was able to find
it in the volume 28 two weeks later and
okay yeah you know I know I'm annoyingly
inquisitive of course at that time and
still to this day so so
um so I went and I it opened you know uh
the you know the book and I started
reading the fatwa and actually what I
read there you know was shocking
that fatwa that religious edict
actually relates to the Mongol invasions
of the Muslim lands in Central Asia in
the uh 11th century sorry in the 13th
century in the early 13th century in the
1200s the Mongols you know had a
practice at the time which is if they
sack one city they take civilians as
prisoners from one city and then they
make them go in front of their armies to
push the siege Towers
towards the walls of the city they want
to sack next so they were asking are we
allowed to kill our fellow Muslims who
are prisoners and they are coerced into
pushing the enemy Siege Towers towards
our walls are we allowed to do that and
the answer was yes because they are dead
anyway so do not add yourself to the
list of the Dead
now
how could this be applied to what
happened in Nairobi and what happened in
Tanzania how can I say that the American
Embassy in Nairobi was pushing Siege
Towers towards Mecca a Medina that there
was a life and death situation that
needed to be dealt with right there
right now I mean it was shocking for me
that you know that my fellow Al-Qaeda
members would violate you know religion
this way to the point not only to a
breaking point but they have broken it
already was it in reading that that you
felt what was happening was the Mufti
was purposefully misinterpreting the
text to see what he wanted to do no
there was no misinterpretation
it was a twisting
it was a complete violation of this and
I for me I felt
no I can't be part of this because you
see for the average jihadist you know
they could waive that question for later
because they say ignorance is bliss yeah
it is truly like for most of them first
they are ignorant of their own faith I
wasn't and they are not you know you
know a trainee bomb makers I was and
therefore the weight you know of this
question on my mind was so great that
one day I will be building one of these
bombs and one day I will be responsible
for a wholesale of death of people who
don't deserve it and I didn't like the
direction you know I thought that I was
being trained as a bomb maker in order
to build the IEDs against tanks against
you know armored vehicles not against
civilian population that's not what I
signed up for and so I decided to live
but the bit that's interesting to me
there is you had signed up as a bomb
maker and you were comfortable that that
would be your role
but was it more that you thought that
the people that would be affected by
your Bonds were people who deserved it
yeah I thought like it would be fighting
against the military until then we were
told we're gonna fight the American
Military in the Middle East
however this is why I always say that
the moment the first atrocity that
Al-Qaeda committed was the East Africa
bombings and it was the first you know
bombings They carried out against the
Americans and I was totally against it
from the beginning because I thought we
will be fighting against American
Military I will be preparing my bombs
for to attack American bases American
tanks American ID you know American
armored vehicles not against you know
embassies or civilians or hotels or any
kind of uh civilian Target like this
um I decided no this is not for me my
friends were going somewhere where I
can't follow anymore it's interesting
because I suppose
all the way back at the beginning of
your journey when you were 16 what you
went to do was I suppose protect people
who you felt were being innocently
executed for the religion and had it
kind of flipped round to the point where
now you were designing bombs which were
going to effectively kill people who had
nothing to do with it absolutely because
I was told we're going to divide the
military but then the First Act was to
go and kill civilians in a wholesale
attack I thought that that's it I can't
be part of this and so I started
plotting my exit
so just to go back a little bit because
I know it was something that we we made
a video before and um something people
were really quite interested in I think
was the logistics of being a a bomb
maker in al-Qaeda like you said there it
was cutting edge uh the way it's
represented in kind of Hollywood films
and things like that is kind of you know
benches with bits of explosive all over
and
shaky hands and if something goes wrong
the whole area gets exploded by accident
is that accurate or is it much more like
a kind of factory Precision if a British
or an American you know a safety expert
were to enter into our lab and to see us
working with chemicals in that manner
they will have a heart attack right they
will say that you know the level of
safety regulations here are so lacking I
mean there is none actually
um no I mean it was just jars and jars
of chemicals you know and powders and
stuff like that like you know I mean and
you know we are just working with
rudimentary you know
um equipment and it was designed like
that because we are supposed to build
bombs you know at the most basic level
so we you know we have to be trained
with the most basic of equipment the
most basic
um you know safety standards uh in order
to be ready to do this at any uh
environment
um and so yeah I mean it looks as if we
are in a very primitive kitchen uh
mixing you know spices but in fact it is
not without ever any disasters you know
did people blow themselves up or poison
themselves because of the lack of safety
restrictions well generally no because I
remember you know from the first day we
uh go into this course first of all at a
at each course which could last months
and months and months there are only
four or five people maximum you know
four people to five people getting the
training so the lesser the number the
lesser the potential for disaster uh
that's the first thing second thing is
that the people are selected you know
for their you know skills for their
wisdom for their lack of being rash
because the worst thing you know you
could do is to be in a hurry when you
are dealing with these chemicals and and
we were always told that treat the
hundredth device you know you are
building as if it was your first you
know never get too confident you know
because you know these are angry
chemicals you know and they could
basically explode in your face your
first mistake is your last mistake you
will never live you know to tell the
tale about the mistake like you make and
so this is why
um you know we were always careful
however disasters do happen between now
and then and in fact there was one
disaster uh in late 1999 where two
people were killed because of the fact
that they were doing it the wrong way
um it's not just only about what
chemicals you mix also the temperatures
because sometimes when you are dealing
with chemicals and you are and you have
a reaction and especially when you are
adding let's say minimum uh you know
sulfuric acid with acetone and these
things and you know
um you are actually raising the
temperature you know the temperature
rising and you hear the sounds of you
know little explosions coming like an I
mean and the smoke and and you always
have a bucket of cold water next to you
to pour over the mix just in case it's
about to explode
um and you are already wearing wet
clothes and you use the Arabic head
scarf is so wet and you are wrapping it
around you know your face these are the
rudimentary you know uh you know safety
measures that we take but we are
absolutely dealing with things that
could go wrong at any moment but they
put us in this situations in order to
test our nerves and to make sure that
actually when we are building in other
locations we will have more comfortable
you know settings because it's
Afghanistan after all I mean basically
you know if I'm doing it in Barcelona if
I'm doing it let's say in London if I'm
doing it in Prague I mean I will be in a
better in a facility I will have better
equipments I will have better chemicals
and better safety environments so it you
know always remember no matter how much
in a better the environment just don't
make that lolio into a false sense of
security got it yeah I mean yeah
yeah I'm based on what you say there
about the uh safety restrictions being
low
um it's amazing to think that what you
had as a kind of safety measure was a
bucket of cold water when you're making
a bomb it seems quite minimal but then
okay so now you've decided to leave
you've made a decision that actually
something's triggered in you and your
morals have been tested you're not happy
and in some ways it mirrors the first
time when you were 16 you have to make a
secret mission to go somewhere that
people don't want you to go to right
yeah and I remember I was you know
thinking about it it was September of
1998 I just two weeks ago I survived a
uh a cruise missile attack by the
Americans because they were retaliating
you know for what happened in Nairobi
and Tanzania and so I was feeling that
again you know there is a divine plan
here Divine Providence that saved me
from uh you know a inevitable death so I
decided that I have to think of
something that is credible and so
um in November the previous year in 1997
I was struck by both typhoid and malaria
and that actually almost killed me and
so I was sent to Qatar for treatment
there and I remember the hospital told
me that there was a problem with your
liver and so we need to check and while
we took care of it we need to check in a
year time you have to come back so we do
the scans and to make sure all is fine
and there is no danger so uh you know so
I thought okay I will inform you know
the leadership that I might have to go
to Qatar again for that medical checkup
because I was told to come back in a
year time and that would be late
November so
everyone agreed to it it seems normal
and yes you can go I mean you know
that's fine
um just make sure you check in with our
friends there and you know our
Associates and so
um you know and this is how I just
landed in uh Qatar in November of 1998.
um and my thinking was that's it I'm not
coming back I remember when I was taking
the flight from Peshawar airport all the
way to Doha I was renouncing my oath of
Allegiance you know I was in the
airplane sitting in the uh in my seat
and I was renouncing the oath of
Allegiance and just leaving this life
behind me and I was thinking that's it
you know I will not see Afghanistan
anymore I was actually looking at you
know when we were flying and I was
looking at you know the uh mountains of
the hybrid pass uh you know uh I can see
the in the mountains of Afghanistan you
know you know from the airplane and I
was thinking that's it goodbye and good
riddance I didn't know that I would be
coming back again and pretty much soon
yeah and that is that's a bit of your
story that's really unusual so how what
happens then so you you fly out you
think that's it I'm gone for good
how do you end up getting sent back
so what happened is that I landed in
Doha in Qatar and I stayed with a friend
for a whole night and then the next day
um I was telling him about my plans and
that I want to leave
um but then of course a phone call comes
from the Qatari intelligence Services
you know telling my friend that you know
the friend that you have
bring him to our building you know and
we don't want any trouble just you know
just tell him he will be well treated
um and so I was dropped there I told him
it's okay do it like that I wasn't I
know uh again like you know because you
know when they say because they are
Bedouins and you know I grew up with
Bedouins all my life in Saudi Arabia so
when they say uh reassure him that he
will not be well he will be well treated
so they mean it so I wasn't uh and they
kept it there you know promised like and
I mean they really treated me well uh
they brought me in uh for questioning
and I noticed that there were so many of
them it's like I'm sitting in one chair
and in front of me there's a table big
long table and on the other side you
know there are nine ten of them I mean
it's like hey I'm being outnumbered here
um and then they told me look you know
to make this easy on you I don't know we
know who you are we know about your
associations with many people like Abu
zubaida and others and we know like in
which camps they went to and you know
that you're a member of the car either
we know a lot about you
um and we were warned of your coming
here
um and they and then I realized from
their line of questioning that they
really knew a lot and that you know uh
you know and I somehow guessed the
reason for that as my association with
Abu zubaida the current uh Guantanamo
Bay inmate
um and the one who was the gatekeeper
you know for many jihadist organizations
including al-Qaeda in Pakistan
so
so they said to me
um look it will make it easier on you I
don't know if you just tell us the truth
you know so we know everything do you
deny that you're a member of Al Qaeda
and now I said no I don't deny anything
I mean everything you said is accurate
um and this is I think where they were
taken aback and they were looking at
each other like they were expecting you
know this in a legendary resistance you
know to questioning and the hostility
and I'm not gonna talk and you can do
your worst this kind of thing and
instead basically me you know sitting
there smiling at them and telling them
yeah it's accurate
uh so you don't deny anything oh no
um okay uh that that's really that can
we expected 45 minutes of you know back
and forth but uh you know okay and you
know why you know why a young fine man
like you big member of a guide so how
old are you at this point uh I was 20 at
that time
so the you know the main officer the one
who was questioning me was asking
um is there something we're missing here
um you seem to be comfortable
um and then you know because you're
telling us you know and you're
incriminating yourself you're telling us
that yes you were trained there and that
you know you have these associations and
you seem to be comfortable telling us
all about it is there something we're
missing uh and I said actually on the
way back I renounced my oath of
Allegiance I was leaving for good
and I remember they said why so I
explained to them exactly how I
explained to you
um it's a crisis of conscience I mean I
just can't you know you know for the
life of me being part of an organization
that will start or embark on a conflict
that will see hundreds of thousands dead
in many countries all over the world
I've seen it even then so
they said just give us few moments so
they went out they switched on you know
the lights from their end and they went
out and you know they took their time
and then they came back
um and then when they were coming back
they were coming to Shake in my hand and
to actually give me hugs however we
think it is better if you are embraced
and protected by a bigger agency that
belongs to a more influential country
than us so we do have a list of
suggestions here for you uh the French
already are happy with the information
that you provided they are willing to
take you there is also the Americans and
they are happy to take you as well as
the British
um so
you know what what will you do and so I
was thinking okay how long do I have to
decide they said 30 minutes
okay and I said wow how generous okay so
um okay give me time and so I went you
know to another office you know they
gave me that office you know to have
this Solitude I prayed I asked God for
guidance you know please you know it was
your will that I leave and now it is
your will that I have to choose either
of these three and I thought French no
forget it I don't like the language at
all I thought about the us but I just
survived the cruise missile attack by
them and I was thinking it's just too
early you know in the day to uh extend
the hand of friendship and so I thought
the British however my grandfather
fought for the British in Iraq he was an
officer uh you know in the uh British
Army in Iraq and
um my father worked for the foreign
office in the past and I was thinking
goodness this definitely runs in the DNA
somehow so
I thought okay the British saw what
looking I mean I thought like and I mean
if it was God's will that I'd go there
it is
um I went back to my hosts and I told
them that I think I would rather like
you know go with the UK so they said
excellent you know and then within 10
minutes I said your flight is tonight I
said yeah but I don't have any paperwork
in a Visa no no don't worry I mean
everything is taken care of you will be
boarded into the plane don't worry you
know and so they put me into the plane
and there in Heathrow I had two people
coming to meet me one from my five one
one from MI6 both are from
counter-terrorism
and at the time we are already now into
December
um of 1998. so they no you know they
they thought that you know uh Father
Christmas you know Santa you know
it might sometimes reside in Afghanistan
because he came from Afghanistan and you
came bearing gifts like that means
information information and so uh so I
was debriefed there for about four hours
um it it helped that both of them uh
spoke good Arabic oh wow
um and they were telling me that my
arrival is very opportune in because
both officers their counter-terrorism uh
you know functions were still small I
mean MI5 are still focusing on the IRA
MI6 was focusing on the former Soviet
Union and the counter proliferation of
nuclear materials however uh terrorism
from the Muslim world was something
there you know functions were still
small and it is expanding and more and
more people are joining from other
departments to beef up this department
and so I was told that you came just at
the right time
and
this is a whirlwind though yeah you've
left your old life you've arrived here
they've said we're not going to arrest
you but you can't stay here where do you
want to live now you're in the UK and
now they're saying to you and we want
you to go back as an undercover spy
it didn't happen like this you know
first there was a debriefing so the
debris things were supposed to last two
months lasted more than that you know
several more months where I would first
establish a good cover story as to why
I'm in London which both the qataris and
the British authorities uh did very well
to actually like you know create that
cover story then after that there was a
question of you know what do I know who
am I connected to what is my position
within uh the jihadist organizations in
Afghanistan uh The Roots the camps the
locations the maps they were enjoying
the fact that they will bring these big
rolled up maps uh you know and I will be
pointing at the locations of camps and
safe houses and bases and uh ammunition
dumps and all of that
um and then the question came in March
of 1999
would you consider going back to
Afghanistan for us we know that we said
that within six seven months we will
start to normalize your life you will be
able to go into a college and uh you
know and we'll make sure that you
graduate and all of that but you know
there are always gaps in our knowledge
that we need to fill so would you
consider going there and I remember I
said without hesitation oh yes I have no
problem whatsoever
um and they said ah we were going to
give you a week or two to consider I
said uh no I don't need a week or two to
consider because I'm bored that's what I
said I'm bored here you know well London
is an amazing City it's just you know I
don't know like I mean was I addicted to
Thrill or you know or something like
that but I actually felt bored so all
the way through your life all the things
you're talking about is what I get from
it is and what's surprising to me you
seem to have a willingness to put
yourself into situations that I would
think were terrifying and I would want
to avoid at all costs and we've kind of
talked about the martyrdom thing earlier
but it does occur to me that you seem to
be lacking a sense of self-preservation
like do you think that's true do you
sense feel like other people do or is it
that you're excited and you're addicted
to excitement
I am I think sometimes I feel that my
sense of Duty overrides all other
considerations and I remember when I was
asked to go back to Afghanistan to spy
you know for the British intelligence
Services I felt that it was my sense of
Duty and I remember when they they asked
me this question they said lucky don't
you feel afraid or terrified to go back
there and this time I said I know there
is an element of danger or element of
risk here but I will be absolute
hypocrite if I was willing to sacrifice
my life for the wrong side and then when
I'm on the right side I become a coward
and I'm not a coward
so you're sent back to Al-Qaeda which is
where you were but this time working on
the side of the British authorities as a
spy
how do you get the information back to
the UK
well we were able to create a very good
cover story that I was going to entice
members of Hawkeye the senior members of
al-Qaeda to work with me on Commercial
Endeavor I know which was to export
items of high value from Afghanistan and
Northern Pakistan into Saudi Arabia and
other Gulf countries it worked so that
enabled me at least to be you know to go
into Pakistan to go into Dubai to go
into Bahrain you know and then from
there with the help and the protection
of the British you know I would give
them you know the information that they
need so it was excellent because then
the senior members of al-Qaeda you know
they are benefiting you know financially
from it you know they are using this
money for their own personal use you
know to get married to have families to
you know have nice houses inside
Afghanistan and to be independent
financially from Al-Qaeda itself so they
don't get just only depend on the meager
salaries that Al-Qaeda is paying them
and this way you know they trust me with
information at least some of some of the
times and I will be able to transmit
that information back you know to uh
mobile phone is that how you did it or
computer oh no no it was unfortunately
you know during that time we were not in
the digital age yet right you know
remember it was 1999 2000 2001 you know
the mobile phones had no cameras you
know you can barely send the text on an
Ericsson or a Motorola I mean you know
oh my goodness I feel old now he's just
mentioning this in the devices and you
know so and computers like in a cannot
be trusted and I can't carry a camera
with me a camera is a death sentence
right you know so therefore I have to
rely purely on my mind you know just
memorizing everything around me you know
looking at the locations you know
Finding geographical features where I
can pinpoint on maps and then when I
finally meet them I will transmit that
information one of the most important
you know aspects of my training before I
was sent back was never ask questions
wow never ask questions let the
information come to you but do not seek
information suspicious yeah because
otherwise you will raise suspicion and
at the same time just do not show any
interest in anything that doesn't
concern you yes it's a trade-off you
know and this is one of the reasons why
for example I get always ask this
question you know you wear a spy inside
in the months and the years before
before 9 11. could how could you not
have seen it coming and I would say well
we've seen it coming that something big
is going to happen but the details were
so well guarded because the al-Qaeda was
split into compartments the people who
were trained for that uh in a mission
were trained in a secret camp that was
set up for them and then they themselves
in at least 14 of them 14 out of the 19
did not know that it was a suicide
mission they thought it was only a
hijacking wow and that's it only five
well even to the point when they were
taking part in the mission absolutely
didn't know Jesus Christ they didn't
know they were actually crashing into
buildings only five you know four pilots
and one of the leaders of the hijackers
and the uh the executive Council of
al-Qaeda 20 of them there are 20
including Bin Laden and his Deputy
abohafs so there are 20 only eight until
the last 48 hours only eight new
including Bin Laden and his Deputy about
9 11 and the details and 12 members of
the executive council did not know and
even when they were informed they were
not informed about the exact details 48
hours before it happened
so even if I was an exec in a member of
the executive Council which means that I
will be 40 years age by by then I I
should be 40 a year old at that time
um they would have been told only very
few details and only 48 hours before the
operation so you said there was an
awareness that something big was
happening yeah it was just it wasn't
clear what that was going to be exactly
so would you in your role would you have
been feeding back the information when
you could that there's something being
planned we're not clear when exactly but
yes because I was tasked with insert the
mission although it was absolutely in
the periphery it is to inform four
people I know here in the UK to leave
the UK as soon as possible and to go to
Afghanistan before the end of August
that's it that was my part in it if they
told me we need you to try to transfer
money
to someone in America then the the
entire plot would have unraveled
but unfortunately you know that task
would have been given to someone else it
all depends on the right time at the
right place you see in order to have
foiled 911 you need 20 spies not just
only one and said was there a suspicion
of spies within Al-Qaeda like always
even before you'd been one where you
were you were aware that there was a
constant suspicion of absolutely always
and there were always random checks here
and there and especially like I mean you
know I myself started to attract
attention more and more because I am
traveling you know all the time and this
is why when people come and confront me
about my constant travels I say oh go to
uh Commander a commander B Commander C
who however like there
um I'm doing all of this for them ah
okay no problem so you see the cover
story about commercial work and
Commercial uh exports like really helped
otherwise I could have been in deep
trouble or I will be there in
Afghanistan and that black hole of
information for months and months unable
to transmit anything were there any
times when you were almost exposed when
you felt like you were very much in
danger or could have been killed for
being found out as a spy no never never
I mean there was of course one random
check uh on me like I mean where I was
in the kitchen one day lucky I mean
because and funny enough it was a
kitchen because the kitchen is where you
are feeling you know safe and secure and
you don't expect any nasty surprises
um you know because all of us have to do
either cooking duties cleaning duties
everyone from the top Commander to the
um you know foot soldier we all have to
do our duties and so I was in the
kitchen and then
you know I noticed that people are
leaving the kitchen you know and I was
alone and then you know someone behind
me you know putting a pistol to the back
of my you know you know to my back to my
spine like I felt really the cold end of
the pistol there I mean uh because it
was November it was really cold and then
I turned around and I saw that it's one
of my friends in the camp and I was
you know looking at him angry I was
saying lower your weapon right now you
know because he was telling me before
that I know who you are I know who
you're working for
it's over the game is over it's done we
know who you work for
now thank God
thank God for the British training
because they alerted me to this before
they told me that when someone comes to
you and say you know we know who you
work for game over that's it it's over
you know you have to confess
you know then they are bluffing
because they don't know who you work for
it could be anyone it could be the
Saudis could be the bahrainis could be
the Egyptians it could be the jordanians
it could be the Russians it could be the
Americans the Israelis whoever so you
know if they have no idea who you work
for it means they have no evidence
against you so stand your ground
immediately you know and do not
volunteer any information so this is why
when he put the pistol at the back of my
at my back and told me that in those
words and trying to be menacing I know
who you work for if he said the British
yeah game is over but he didn't say he
said I know who you work for you know we
know you're a spy you know that's it
game over so I just looked back to him
and I was expressing my anger that this
is a sick joke and I'm not going to
tolerate it I was thinking it was a joke
um and
you know when he was taken aback by the
level of anger I was having at him and
telling him to lower his weapon and I'm
not going to tolerate this and I will
report it to the camp Commander he was
telling me actually the camp Commander
asked me to check on you and others
actually because you are perfect yeah
The Travelers you know those who travel
a lot like you know they are they need
to be shaken down between now and then
I'm sorry brother it's nothing personal
I was just told to do it was my duty you
know no it's okay it's fine like you
know I don't even doubt you you know so
but it's a random check so it had to be
done
I mean what I'd like to get onto now is
you've been back in there you've been a
spy for how long how long will you spy
for I spent seven and a half years seven
and a half oh my God I didn't realize it
was that long actually so seven and a
half years as a spy and then what
happened that exposed you was a spy and
meant you had to stop
well
in my life as a normal human being I
remember it was
June of 2006 and I've already had many
tours in Afghanistan in the gulf and
Lebanon and Australia and Europe like I
mean so by that time I was you know and
here in the UK I was already weary and I
said like I mean I've never been in a
normal holiday like a normal human being
you know is it possible to go to Paris
I've never been there
um and my Handler said yeah of course
for God's sake yes please do
um sorry we neglected that aspect you
know so yeah you can so I was in Paris
and then out of nowhere while I was on
the Riverboat you know having a look at
the city uh I received a text message
you know from an associate of mine
within Al-Qaeda and the gulf and Bahrain
and he was telling me you know uh
brother there is a spy Among Us go into
hiding read the Time magazine article
they are talking about the book is about
to come go and read it and so I was
thinking
that's worrying but then the you know
I'm in the middle of a boat I can't just
jump into the river I mean I waited
until
um you know we arrived at docking
um he left the boat it was hotel de
Ville I was going to find an intimate
Cafe yes for the Millennials who are
watching this internet cafes are
something that existed you know in the
past in order to go and find information
so so I went to internet cafe I uh you
know switched on the uh you know the the
Internet Explorer I remember at that
time you remember the a symbol and all
of that
um went into the Time Magazine website
and the first thing there it is an
article advertising for a book that is
about to come in a week time and this
article says the U.S had a brilliant spy
in sadokaid
and I was thinking ah it's okay like
they're talking about the U.S spy not
the British one and then I started
reading and the more I read the more I
felt that you know my heart was sinking
all the way down to my stomach uh
because it it really talked about me
about operations that I was involved in
oh my God yeah you know whether it is a
chemical attack plans in New York Subway
uh you know a massive attack that was
planned against the uh U.S Sailors of
the fifth Fleet in Bahrain
um you know and the outing of an
important leader in Saudi Arabia and
which led to his death you know so all
of these were part of uh operations that
I was the common denominator you know
among them and so
and then they decided to give me my real
name even you know my first real name
the birth name I had
I was in the article in the article
because he said let's find a name for
him let's call him Ali you know and so I
was thinking out of 4 000 bloody names
in Arabic couldn't you find any any
other name except Ali and then you
identify me as having a Bahraini
Heritage I mean you might as well put a
Crosshair on me you know and so I how
did this happen it was a leak you know
from the office of the Vice President of
the United States you know to this
journalist you know in the US
ronstoskind who wrote a book called the
one percent doctor on 46 pages of that
book were talking about me and my in the
operations I was
um involved in in terms of intelligence
gathering on behalf of the British
services but
you know they have the audacity to claim
that it was American operations well in
fact I was working for the British talk
about being a vassal state area so I
know so
um I read all of this so I went uh to
the nearest uh you know phone booth
again for the Millennials in these are
boxes where phones used to be there you
put coins and you so I I called you know
the emergency line it was Sunday so I
called the emergency line you know to
MI6 you know uh and I said you know
please get you know my Handler his name
is so and so you know to call me on my
mobile phone as soon as possible it's an
emergency I'm in Paris five minutes
later he was on the phone and I said to
him go and read the Time Magazine
website please come back to me and tell
me what to do you know give me
instructions he came back to me you know
and he was using lots of F words about
the situation and he was saying don't
worry just you know come back to
Waterloo at that time it was the
Waterloo Station you know when we come
back from garden Northern Paris so come
back to Waterloo we'll be waiting for
you and we are already sending a car now
to your apartment in order to clear it
clean it take everything you know so you
will not go back there we will take you
somewhere else in England and I arrived
back you know so both my handlers from
MI5 and MI6 were waiting for me
um they gave me hugs and assurances you
know don't worry this isn't the end we
will take care of you you know we don't
know how this has happened and already
phones are ringing into you know DC
trying to understand what really
happened here uh it's a major league
here so
um so they took me to Oxford you know
into the Randolph Hotel just next to the
ashmolean museum there I spent uh
several days there in a while you know
people were coming to Oxford every day
to you know from both organizations to
assure me uh while assuring me that they
will deal with it they're also telling
me that my spying Days Are Over You know
so and I guess at that moment you were
out yeah that's it you know I'm exposed
the question is you know now what to do
and then it was decided in the end that
there was a senior member of the
organization of MI6 is leaving is
retiring and he is going to take up a a
senior Post in one of the global Banks
and he said I want him to come with me
he will be good on counter-terrorism
finance he understands the aspects of
the terrorism finance and the workings
of their Banking and Charities and
hawala systems and the money men and the
exchanges he knows so I need them with
me so
and that's how it was decided I'm
exchanging one form of terrorism to
another being a banker is you know I
think it's it's in the same moral
equivalence of being a bomb maker I
think oh my god well I need the audience
to draw their own uh decisions on that
right Eamon the problem with talking to
you is you're so fascinating you've just
got so much so many interesting stories
that we've gone over and there's three
questions I want to ask you so the first
question
do you still look over your shoulder
the answer is yes and no in a sense that
yes I have to be careful
but also no because the security
measures taken in order to safeguard
myself and my family you know are so
extensive you know that more or less I
feel much more secure than I used to be
for example three four years ago
a lot of the stuff that happened in your
life was inspired initially by religion
for good and for bad are you still
religious
yes I mean everything that I've seen in
my life
yeah you have to be religious but in
what sense ritualistic no spiritualistic
yes
there's a talking to you is so
interesting because I've met people
before who've been on undercover I've
met people who've served in the military
in different positions and all of them
seem to have had quite a sort of
heavy load put onto their conscious and
their soul
there's kind of an element to you that I
find just fascinating in a sense that
you seem able to process and deal with
very severe situations in a way that it
doesn't seem to me to have left an
emotional toll on you and maybe it's
because you've been you know trained in
interviews trained in how to speak and
you're good at hiding that or passing it
away but how do you feel as a person all
the things you've gone through the the
aspects of fear seeing people killed
being responsible for deaths to things
like that stay with you or are you able
to just kind of pass them on they stay
with you but you know how to process
them why because do you remember at the
beginning I told you about the divine
plan it's all part of a divine plan and
that's why I have no regrets and
whatever happened to other people is all
part of a divine plan it's not my part
to question it it's just you go with the
flow
you go with the flow
brilliant and the final question before
we finish
what's next for you
well I mean what's next for me I mean
I've been living you know in the UK on
and off for almost 24 years now and you
know like when they say that when you
fight for people you become part of them
somehow
this
um
concept been challenged so much over the
past year because you know over the past
year I started question
whether I belong here whether I
belonging to the you know in the UK or
not whether I belong in Europe if even
to begin with and I think this is all
due to the fact that it's different when
you are a single person with no family
but then when you have a family and you
have kids and these kids are going into
schools you know how then you know their
sense of belonging will be developing I
remember I insisted that you know I want
my children to grow up here because
that's the only citizenship they have
that's the only nationality they have
you know as UK citizens
um but then the events of the past year
you know made me question whether
actually we as a family whether my kids
you know belong here because my daughter
goes to a school in Edinburgh and you
know for girls and that
School along with parents who were there
you know did not look kindly on the role
I played in ensuring the security of
this country for you know seven and a
half and eight years that I worked for
the UK intelligence services and then
the 12 years I worked in the banking
sector you know identifying tracking and
disrupting terrorism Finance they looked
at it as if you're on a risk you know
you shouldn't be you know here your
daughter shouldn't be in school with us
and with our daughters and so they did
their best you know over a year to try
to really like you know I mean make us
feel and welcome to the point where they
said that's a head teacher of that
school telling you know me don't expect
a welcome in Scotland God
and they are telling us like you know
why don't you consider leaving the
country for the well-being of your kids
because you will never be accepted here
so I thought you know what
let's pack and leave
because
the question of whether we belong or not
has been settled in my opinion
yeah unfortunately and where have you
decided on
Arabia
going back yes
well look Eamonn it's the second time
we've met you it's just as fascinating
to hear the stories the second time is
the first and um thank you so much for
your time and coming in again wish you
and your family the best of luck with
the new adventures and uh thank you so
much thank you love yourself much
appreciated thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so that was Eamon Dean uh who was an
ex-al-qaeda terrorist turned MI5 mr6 spy
I'm joined now by the director of the
episode Josh
I mean that was a big episode what man
what an incredible life yeah
um I think we could have done the whole
series just on his stages of his of his
life
um what was your biggest takeaway from
what is that now why I find him such an
incredible character because we've
talked to other people who've done I
mean not all those things I mean even at
the end he talked about how he went into
banking which is a whole career for some
people but
um it's the
coolness the calm collectedness you know
the other people that we talk to that
have done similar things quite often
have long lasting mental impact yes you
feel it on them that's a nice way to
describe it where's with amen you know I
kind of came back to him a couple of
times through the discussion and just
sort of said you just don't seem to have
an impact
I think that's obviously what served him
so well that ability to just mold into
the next thing
um and we were talking about like he's
just completely switched on the drop of
a coin from sides and has done that
throughout and I think that is quite a
rare thing to be able to do so well and
then to put yourself in the risk that he
did turning as a spy
it on your own completely but doing the
same life you need that ability just to
focus in on why you're there I think
there was another there was you know
because he comes across as such an
unassuming gentle gentle yeah friendly
man and there was a comment from the
first video we did with him on YouTube
that I always remember uh reading which
was did you need a reinforced chair for
this episode due to the size of this
guy's balls and it's sort of a bit of a
throwaway colors comment but I genuinely
just even again speaking to him then I
was just thinking I couldn't do what he
did either side you know yeah what did
you think bryony I what struck me was
his really calm energy despite
everything that he has been through and
what he was describing which is
experiences that none of us can even
possibly imagine and he said it with
such Clarity and calmness
that he must have something really deep
inside him that allows him to
have that kind of assurance maybe
religion maybe the religious yeah I was
thinking that but then at 16 to go and
choose to do that I almost felt like by
the end of it I thought religion would
be a big part of it but how quickly he
dropped his sort of deep held extremist
beliefs when he switched or to be fair
to him when he saw what the results of
his actions and al-qaeda's were
and then you know and the other bit was
when he was in London and he didn't
become a spy straight away and get sent
back he just basically said I was bored
in London so I think that 16 year old
self and the going back spot I think he
sought out that adventure and I think
that was probably more powerful
personality trait in defining his life
than religion it was a bit where he was
talking about everything he'd gone
through and he'd come out of it and he
decided to renounce everything and then
he was back and they picked him up from
his friends and was saying don't worry
we're not going to hurt you and we're
going to actually figure it out and then
I said how old are you at this point he
said 1920. it's just like my God and
again yeah it's not on him he's not
carrying this stuff he feels quite just
like a normal Bank clerk when he walks
in
um what did you both take away from it
I guess what I took from it is
careful
how sure you are that you're right
at the moment in the world everything's
getting increasingly polarized even in
the UK politics you know it's it's not
it doesn't feel like anymore it's kind
of a big discussion about what's the
best way to help this country it feels
more like if I'm this side it means I
hate your side
and it was interesting to me when he was
talking about you know it's it's a
cliche which he said but he said the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions and he said without wisdom
it's not enough well it's a very
interesting point from someone who's
fought on two opposing sides of a war
yeah and it's like the biggest
International issue of Our Generation
what he's been at the Forefront of and
you know I do kind of go you know his
remorse of
being at Al-Qaeda being a bomb maker and
then oh it's all different now he saw
what a bomb could do and I kind of went
into that a bit prejudiced if you like
like I was like too let's probably quiz
that a little bit because if you're
making bombs they're going to use
something but then he was like
we're against America I thought we were
going to go for military targets and
that's what my work was and if they're
the evil enemy which is what Al-Qaeda
that is the philosophy so it kind of he
did have an answer for that a bit and
then when he saw in the East Africa
um attacks that
um you know hundreds of civilians were
collateral damage and he couldn't live
with that I kind of I believed him and
then it's very brave to go
these are what I've dedicated my life to
but I'm gonna I'm gonna leave and then
to then fight fight them in such a risky
and covert ways it is admirable and uh
yeah the amount of impact he's had
positively in protecting people from
being an undercover spy it's probably
impossible to fully fully gauge
Interpol
shop a flight
um interpol on my case
um
tracked all my flights they knew what I
was doing and yes it's the biggest
pharmaceutical bust in Spanish history
and still is
a quarter of a million pills and 50 000
amules and that's just you yeah right
okay so
what happens next